each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
right okay the second and last speaker
in this session is Bob Bukowski from
Cornell who will be talking about the
violating procedure good afternoon I'm
going to be talking more specifically
about the web service extension of the
bio hpc to set and the plan of my talk
is the following first I'm going to
explain a little bit what is CBS you
computational biology service unit that
I represent then I'm going to talk a
little bit about what by ohpc is in
these two first points will sure seem
like there's a blue for those of you who
attended the MDF workshop yesterday so
my apologies in advance then I'm going
to talk about the actual topic of this
present which is the web service
extension of the bio hpc system I'm
going to describe a couple of sample
clients which are still worked work in
progress and then I'm going to present
the conclusions so first of all
computational biology service unit
design a member of is it's one of the
core facilities of the life scientists
sciences core laboratory center at
Cornell University will live on the
sixth floor of this funny-looking
building which is called Rose Hall and
it is in ithaca new york cornell campus
our mission is to provide by informatics
and computational support for biological
research at cornell we have several
subgroups in our little group we have a
genomics and proteomics group who is
participating in cutting-edge
cutting-edge research collaborating with
various laboratories at Cornell we have
one member specializing in systems
biology and we have a couple we have a
few people myself included on the HPC
side and we are okay so these are just a
few examples of the projects that our
proteomics and genomics group is
involved in
and I'm going to be talking too much
about those projects what I'm going to
say about is there is a one common
denominator that are binds them together
and this is the use of next-generation
sequencing techniques which are
generating a lot of data and require a
lot of computational power to process
and we are there to actually provide
this computational power and for that
purpose we are maintaining several
compute clusters which we made available
not only for the projects that we are
explicitly involved in but also to a
broader Cornell community to people who
are we need some computational power to
do their calculations using well-defined
and ready-made programs and just need
the platform to run it on and if we can
spare any of this power we can actually
make it available to the world as well
and the prerequisite to these last two
points is to simplify access to the HPC
resources because usually as it was
pointed out here during keynote speeches
people want to do science rather than
write scripts and interface with cluster
schedulers and so on and so forth so
simplification of access to hpc is
actually hpc i should say it's actually
a very important issue here and we
accomplished this task with the help of
our product that we have been developing
for a number of years now which is
called bio HPC so let me explain our
word by ohpc is so first of all it is a
suite of open source computational
biology applications which are developed
by many different researchers in the
research groups all around the world we
collect them install them on our
clusters make them available to be for
people to run sometimes we have to
modify them and adapt them for efficient
use in windows hpc environments
sometimes it requires tasks like pop
paralyzation for example another aspect
of bio HPC another part I would say to
sometimes synonymous with bio HPC is a
web-based user interface that we present
through
users so that they can submit jobs
through it it's written in asp.net it
contains job application pages which I
will show you in a minute example of it
and it contains a lot of job user
application data management features as
well and let's look at the at our bio
HPC web page on the left hand side you
can see applications that we that we
offer so we have a lot of data sequence
data mining applications cluding blast
hammer and interprets can't for example
we have some alignment software
installed we have a lot of population
genetics programs which actually take
the majority of our CPU capabilities we
have a couple of protein modeling
programs and we recently added
interfaces to Microsoft Research
biomedical applications so the way it
works is that for instance somebody
wants to run blast if he or she opens
the blast webpage fills up a few answers
a few questions on the submission form
for instance how to present the query to
the server you can copy it you can
upload the file you can actually taste
sequences here in the FASTA format you
can select the database or databases
because we can select multiple databases
to blast against we can select some
other run parameters last tuning
parameters and you can click blast which
submits a blaster job so once the job is
submitted the user gets an email
confirming this fact and when the job
starts executing there is another email
being sent when the job ends the user
gets another email and that's how that's
how he knows that the job is completed
actually what we saw there
it's just the tip of the iceberg the
user just interacts with the web server
this web service the web page is
presented from the web server but there
is much more to that we actually the
system actually consists of a lot of
different components and it's quite
complicated both both hardware and
software wise first of all we have to
have some clusters that the jobs are
running on we have the file server to
store the jobs data we have the sequel
server which is keeping track of the
jobs first of all and second of all is
storing the configuration of the whole
system finally we also have an ftp
server for longer turn data storage so
this is all tied up into what we call by
ohpc interface it the good news is
although it looks kind of complicated
the good news is is that actually all of
these or most of these functions can be
performed by just one single servers for
example sequel server web server file
server nft p server if you wish they can
all be just one physically just one
machine for example the head node or the
cluster so for smaller installations
this kind of strategy will work as well
bio hpc is an open source project we
have an installation package available
at this link here by ohpc dot org this
is not a point and click installation
simply because there's a lot of elements
involved in it we have several
installations of the system running our
primary CPSU installation and a couple
of hours as well a little bit of
statistics of bio HPC usage this plot
kind of illustrates in terms of CPU time
the usage of of the system we consider
is growing kind of consistently over the
years the Plus also shows the
distribution of the CPU time between
different types of applications you can
see that population genetics is the most
time consuming part here followed by the
protein structure prediction and the
word is called here sequence analysis
which basically means blast runs mostly
we have about 3,500 unique users
worldwide I think we calculated recently
that they come from 88 countries the
total number of countries actually in
the world is 1 9 192 which makes it
almost fifty percent most of the most of
these users come from the United States
this is followed closely by France and
Canada and many other countries so on
why do we want to expose by ohpc as a
web service well first of all we could
if we do that we could free ourselves
from the web browser as a primary
interface the system so you can write if
we have a web service we can write
clients and any on any platform that we
that we wish for example Microsoft Excel
and in many cases it would be beneficial
for the update for the applications
because if you if we can submit a job
from a client like this and then and
then download a result this result could
be easily visualized immediately using
Excel tools for example i'm going to
show a little example of that later on
second we would like to incorporate HPC
applications and automated analysis
pipelines which is especially important
in the context of the next-generation
sequencing pipelines which we are now
working on and thirdly it would make
exposing BIOS bc as a web service would
make it available through microsoft
biology gunday found about a micro cell
biology foundation which would become
sort of a client to the HPC resources in
particular it would benefit from bio HPC
since we have a lot of population
genetics applications involved in our
system which are not represented in the
NBF yet so there's a few factors to
consider when we want to when we
thinking about the a web service by pc
web service so first of all
we have a wide variety of applications
38 right now which are doing different
things they are accepting different
input and producing really different
output you want to make the system
Universal enough to kind of serve all
these applications the second point of
the most important point here is that
many of these applications are talking
to the user in terms of files so they
are input to them is a lot of files
sometimes these files may be large
several gigabytes event and the output
from these applications could also be
multiple files and some of them also may
be large so we are facing the problem
file staging here which kind of dictates
how the the job submission process has
to be implemented well first we have to
have to first we have to allocate the
job which we kind of define the space
for it for example in our file server to
store the files in while the job is
allocated you can actually stage the
input files then we can submit the job
so it's just not one command anymore
it's justin has to be three commands
really that make up this job submission
process the last point to consider which
is more of a point for a client rather
than the web service itself is that most
of our jobs are not taking seconds or
minutes they are taking days sometimes
they are taking weeks so the the issue
is that the user has to be able to come
back and using this client he has to be
able to come back to the jobs that he
submitted days ago so with these all
these factors in mind we implemented our
web service we wrote it in asp.net the
link to the asmx file is where you can
find this web service now on the client
side we wrote basically we are making
available at file containing this bio h
pc web service client namespace which is
basically containing the service proxy
class without met webmethods and and
structures which the service like
exports and also a couple of others
no rapper functions for 45 staging this
is the files often updated because we
are still adapting new applications to
the web service so some more data
structures are being are being exported
you can actually try it out the current
version of it this is the the second
link here is the link to a zip file
containing a very simple command-line
application in the form of the visual
studio 2008 solution which illustrates
how to how to use the service and also a
word document and PDF document I believe
also with the description of the service
so in a nutshell what we have here the
most important objects exported by the
service is this class called up input
data which contains essentially data
structures that the user has to fill out
in order to to submit an application
that contains some application specific
substructures say and it exports a class
called bio HPC client which contains the
actual web methods used for submitting a
job and these are kind of listed here
more or less in the order that they
would be used in a client so first we
have to create a job I mean to specify
what kind of application we are we
wanted to run so this first parameter
app ID tells the service just that we
need to specify the job name number of
nodes to run it on we also need to
specify an email because we always want
to keep track of the users who use our
system and the password password is
actually optional we can specify it or
leave it leave it empty our registered
users enjoy who have the password
actually they enjoy a little bit more
privileges than the guest users they
enjoy a longer time outs for example and
also they can have access to
applications that the guest users don't
have access to so after the job is
created we can actually initialize the
input data to the two defaults and this
is also a web service function after
that is done we can up
float the input file and again you can
see that for example the function upload
input file it takes the job ID and
control number these two things define a
job job ID is just the consecutive
number of the job generated by the
sequel server so this is not the mystery
to anybody is no secret but the control
number is like a random random integer
number which serves as a sort of a
password to the jobs resources so you
have to have these two and they have too
much in order for you to be able to
access access the job files for example
so upload file after the file is
uploaded we can submit the job then we
can check the status of the job using
the get job info function we can cancel
cancel the job we want to and finally
when the job is finished you can
download the arm output files using this
download file function possibly multiple
times depending on how many output files
our job generate sometimes Joe a job
generates a simple output file Canaan
output file which we would rather have
as a string retrieved as a strength as a
file and then there's another function
made available here get out with a
string which can be used for this
purpose give the programming example I
don't want to spend too much time on it
because it sort of follows what's in the
demo client the link to this client is
repeated here on this on this page so
client so as I said clients are kind of
work in progress right now first of all
because not all of the bio HPC
applications are exposed as a web
service yet and I'm already talked about
this simple command-line demo client we
also have a couple of Excel clients to
show you also in the early stages of
development but probably we're showing
already so first I'm going to show the
native CBS you client that we have been
developing here we have the bio HPC
tools tab and after pressing the tab
this set of buttons come come up here so
the first thing to do would be to login
like to log in as myself and once we
look in we can we have access to
different job submission kyle's so for
example here in the group sequence
analysis what we implemented so far is
blast hammer and and interprets can we
also have one application so far exposed
as a web service from ms our researchers
create a Piton what i wanted to show you
is an application called called m.div
this is one of the population genetics
applications well it does is kind of
trying to estimate the various
parameters in this scenario where you
have two populations diverging from one
ancestor of ancestral population with
some migration taking place in between
and well it's basically it's a Monte
Carlo simulation it may be may be
lengthy but this form here kind of
illustrates how a job can be submitted
we just select a data file which
contains basically some sequence data
that this simulation is based on some
default parameters are already filled up
here just can click Submit that's right
now it's trying to upload the file and
it did that and the five has been
successfully uploaded now we can use a
little tool show jobs here it's like a
job administrator pretty much we can
select what kind of application we want
to see here so i'm going to select md
because this is what i submit it and i
can see several end endif jobs here
including this last one which is queued
so it probably gonna is going to remain
cute for a while because this is working
on the live system it's probably backed
up a little bit so it's not going to
execute immediately but
you probably can expect I have some
ready-made results here from similar
jobs for example this job finished
before and I can by clicking on the show
output files I can see what kind of
files this job produced some reason is
not displaying here with this resolution
as I said this is a work in progress
what you should see here is the sizes of
those files for example I can select any
number of files that I want and I can
try to download them this is letting me
select the directory to download it into
an alternative would be to import the
main file directly into Excel which
results in immediate visual analysis of
those results the results that the
program returns happen to be in this
numerical form basically and the and
what it is that they are posterior
probability distributions of different
parameters and these of course can be
plotted so I can do it automatically
here in Excel create the plots so this
is basically the direction that that our
native CBS you interface is a big client
Excel client is going into now you can
see another tab here which is called
bioinformatics and for those of you who
attended the MDF workshop yesterday it
should be familiar because this takes
you to the MDF XL client pretty much and
what I wanted to show you here is that
the blast web service from bio HPC is
actually implemented in NBF already and
basically fetch the database names here
they will change when i change the blast
program to run essentially we can treat
this little interface is a beginning of
our collaboration with the MDF team and
eventually
I think the goal would be to make the
bio bio HPC interfaces BIOS pc tools
kind of being merged with with the NBF
to eventually so this is actually all I
wanted to tell you about it basically
conclusions are the following the core
of the bios PC web service has been
developed we have some applications
already exposed as a web services and we
are working on adding others we have our
blast lip service integrated with
microsoft biology foundation we have our
comprehensive except I interned under
development and the devil project can be
downloaded from this link and finally I
wanted to acknowledge funding from
Microsoft Research and before that we
enjoy it relationship with Microsoft as
one of the HPC institutes and we also
want to thank Microsoft mbf team for
fruitful collaboration thank you
are there any questions yes there's a
question right
okay so we the bio HPC interfaces with a
cluster scheduler so we work with the
HPC 2008 and ccs cluster so basically
when we submit a job to the cluster we
submit the job to these schedulers so
basically that's that's it we do not
really have any priority based
scheduling implemented at this point so
basically the cluster scheduler itself
takes care of it from the it kind of
depends because the usage varies widely
by time so sometimes the cluster our
clusters are almost empty and then your
job goes in immediately and sometimes
you have to wait for a couple of days
for example to get it kind of depends
what jobs are run what kind of jobs are
run
and it does actually
it's actually you're running LC is
Ronnie
well actually you would really like to
see the bio HPC numbers sorry hpc basic
profile would like to see it support
thing multi task jobs for example it
doesn't support that yet for the desk
that's one thing yeah especially the new
one especially that you can submit a
multi task job and these tasks are
actually dynamically assigned and the
resources are dynamic is
so right now the situations that remote
clusters do not support the same
features of the scheduler as the local
cluster simply because by this HPC basic
profile that's not supported so this is
what we would like we kind of Freya we
would like to see that the defect or we
would have to ask the operators of these
remote clusters to install our version
of the submission web service which they
may or may not want to
right now it's 38 last time I counted
it's 38 programs should we show them
again here is the list on the left hand
side I need to show all and scroll well
first of all they are kind of grouped
into several groups so you can sequence
on a sequence analysis we have alignment
population genetics protein structure
and so on when we expand there you can
see the details what kind of programs
exactly we are offering so with that
there is a few programs that you all
know it's blast and hammer interprets
can the P in front of this means that
they are paralyzed so they run we
utilize many cores to to run those jobs
on a multi sequence query and there are
some others which also serve the purpose
of analyzing the sequence in the broad
sense we have population genetics
programs here we have a couple of
protein structure prediction programs
one of them loop is actually very
popular in kind of takes second place as
when it comes to CPU consumption
this is a good question uh I would say
that most of okay most of these programs
yeah it depends on what kind of program
group you are you are talking about for
example blast hammer interprets can we
know that we can run them somewhere else
for example NCBI can run blast right
interpose can we can run also through
observed through their websites or even
web services so so these are of course
not not unique some of them are unique
for example this games on program this
is a locally developed program by
cornell resources and it's available
only here of course clustalw tea coffee
they have other sites where you can run
it stretcher i'm not sure this is just a
pairwise alignment problem i don't know
if you can run it on the web anywhere
else i know that these population
genetics programs are completely unique
you can you cannot run it on the web
anywhere else you can download the
executables and you can run it on your
own laptop if you want because they are
all open source applications which are
distributed freely but if you but if
your laptop is backed up with stuff then
you don't you don't want to run it them
by popular demand pretty much so
essentially we interact with our users
and once know why we get a request ache
and you know I have this program here I
would really like to run it because I
have some data to analyze with this
program and I need some computational
power can you just instantly for me and
we get inquiries
so what's your question who's paying for
it okay
yeah and called the cornell users that
mean mention that cornell users have
priority here they can be registered
they can run more jobs and they Quran
jobs longer okay
yeah that's in the plants
okay well sadly we'll have time for this
session but it sounds like you've got
some topics of coffee break as well so
please join me in thanking all the
speakers